[Musique]
mais jusque là le best-of sérieux parce
que tu as sabah de la semaine prochaine
mais voit ce qui se passe c'est ce
qu'estime le mari s'est tourné vers un
cours égal et les gens m'ont dit on a
besoin de rigoler ah ben oui droit
valorise belle et on se parle à williams
à boire la williams pour la golden j'ai
remarqué les les actrices de films
pornos elles ont toujours des noms de
fruits
c'est vrai donegal bay a seriné denis
golden carrey morgan morgan c'est une
voiture comme n'y a pas d'autres comme
on avait un peu le retard annoncé ces
professionnels leur sauver la vie il ya
johnny c'est vrai sur la digue route sur
ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas un truc
bigou gérard que oui alors que oui
gérard ivy bean girard qui oui tu n'es
pas dit oui parce qu'il a des poils sur
le allez sortez charest
voir broderie barre toi
bon alors tout à l'heure on saura qu'il
33ème tabac même s'ils ont déjà suite
sera le 34e la semaine prochaine on l'a
déjà mais on tacle ici c'est niveau
ligue des champions alors oui ça se
rentrent dedans
en tout bien tout honneur mais ça se
rentrer dedans toujours avec amour pour
le meilleur tacle de la semaine les
nommés sont isabelle morini bosc qui ne
taclent jamais mais quand elle tacle
c'est à la gorge les chansons pas dire
d'habitude ils sont janvier là sont marc
burg a pas l'habitude son janvier
cyril hanouna qui sait mettre en valeur
son frérot benjamin castaldi la phase
iii c'est le contraire on n'est pas
confiné comme en vidéo c'est pas ça n'a
rien à vider les gens peuvent circuler
sur nos responsables des rues si on
regarde et gilles verdez qui a tellement
de mal à rester calmes que quand il
rechute
c'est violent on ne peut plus défiler en
maillot de bain vous calmer on me
demande mon avis le dol vous donnerez
votre après si on vous donne la parole
ce qui n'est pas sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour
on voit ses droits pour moi tu es gillot
ça fait six mois qu'on peut aussi eu l
avoue il qu elle y tient un don
incroyable un captain importe fois ouais
d'accord on espère vous attrapez pas
comme ça je vous avoue l'un des trois
livres de trois livres là c'est trop
violent
c'est trop violent vous voulez qu'on
fasse un combat d'auteur sans
oreillettes serait préférable
j'enlève sans fil et misérable annoncée
mais qui pose des questions ça va pas me
reposer la zola
[Rires]
c'est bon enfant du couple est fatigué
merci jour là ça alors c'est un joueur
de foot il ya seulement trois stars de
limitation en france canteloup gerra le
bray et il ya donc de la place pour des
nouveaux talents d'irritation et ici on
a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'imitateurs et ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il ait bientôt spectacle au théâtre
des deux ânes
alors pour les awards du meilleur
imitateur de la semaine les nommés sont
valérie bénaïm et on fait tourner c'est
embêtant et ne revenir plus amer cyril
hanouna
que doit-on avoir chez soi en cas de
confinement et bien je vous le dire mais
je voulais dire on doit voir dans trois
kilos et demi au total de céréales
prenez ont des milliers de personnes
deux minutes plus là et isabelle
morini-bosc me that us et mythique qui
chérit aulas qui vous saisit pour ces
dames c'est confondant hyper bien mieux
à le faire avec un dentier hyper bien
chier non je pensais que c'était mieux
on est dans la non attends c'est
saisissant
donc tu le cac a pris par la maison
j'aime bien d'imiter oui des fois ça
m'est déjà arrivé vers mon mari je fais
qui ouais mais qu'on ne trouve jamais vu
notre nombre à sallanches aime beaucoup
ils vous le rendent bien un jour je
viendrai dîner chez vous alors ça je
payerai pour voir ça va payer moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis bien s'y mettre en
quarantaine chez isabelle ou pas du tout
ah ouais franchement je crois qui fit
zabel c'est un amour j'adorerais -
franchement mais ça c'est sympa ça mais
bien sûr pour est en quarantaine chez
tout le monde y allait d'un côté de chez
rachid arhab en plus vous habitez passe
au théâtre d'humour alors tpm p120
justement c'est quand même bounty son
autre coco ça sert à rien mais ici les
vannes ça fuse comme les fluides de
jamais castaldi alors pour la meilleure
veine de la semaine voici les nommer
jean michel maire qui prouve qu'il aime
bien les chiens et qui préfère quand
même les meufs et enfin encore emilie la
ola elle absolument que voilà je vois
recèle comme chaque week end à nous
allons faire une photo depuis son lit
voilà laurent baffie il semble beaucoup
apprécier la présence de raymond à bout
c'est par un concours qui va être plus
fort et qui va chanter le mieux c'est la
cause par des sketchs et ans aimerait
c'est usant mais au moment où raymond
t'as pas une course sur le cyril hanouna
qui donne envie à matthieu delormeau de
prendre plus souvent le métro et la
personne qui a pris le kkk ouvert le
rideau va vous voyez sur les gens ne
diminuent quelqu'un vous fait des photos
qui choque dans l'histoire avait
carrément dans le métro ça ne choque pas
du tout ban on a bon moral ratp
rassemblement autour d'un terrible pénis
[Applaudissements]
parce que tout le monde ya pensé et vous
l'avez bien formulée jean michel a bien
tu es vraiment jésus là pour ça c'est
vrai que sniper de charme ça qui est
bien alors ce que j'aime depuis je
regarde tp mpc qui a tout il ya les
meilleurs chroniqueurs du 92 rescousse
médias et surtout du raffinement là
c'est vrai dans cette émission
franchement y'a pas un mot plus haut que
l'autre
la courtoisie tout le temps et et des
fois je regarde ni centre ni est-ce que
ce soit sur france culture la question
là bas des gens nous écrivent pour
savoir si c'est vrai alors pour l'amour
du raffinement si vous intéresse ou pas
ou bien sûr et bien regarder les nommer
tout
cyril hanouna qui aime ses chroniqueurs
et peut-être même un peu trop
j'ai envie de faire un gros spectacle de
casse à la fin de l'année pour le
dernier serait pas sans déconner c'est
un jour participer enfin demain je
cachais de casser le cul bernard montiel
qui depuis qu'il est sur ces 8 est
devenu plus loubards que joey starr en
tant qu'animateur est ce que tu trouves
qu'il est talentueux et matthieu
delormeau qui s'inquiètent pour le
coronavirus et qui pose la question que
tout le monde attendait mais en chine il
faisait chaud pareil et y avait quand
même du corps d'alain sur l'opérateur
docteur mois ses choix du cul un risque
vous voulez que je vous dise la vérité
jeudi tous les états unis si tu poses
toi même je double ton cash
[Rires]
ces deux là rien je connais de nom de
leurs mots c'est plus drôle de nom n'est
pas habitué quand même à le voir n'était
alors pas de manière cachée musique du
suspense bien sûr musique de suspense
qui a taclé le plus ses collègues cette
semaine qui sera le tabac pour la 33e
fois de l'histoire de touche pas à mon
poste
cyril chavet une déclaration à faire aux
français
chers compatriotes
nous traversons actuellement une crise
majeure mais néanmoins ça ne nous
empêchera pas de continuer
à se charrier les uns les autres je sais
que j'ai gagné 32 fois ce tard baba et
je pense
avoir été à la hauteur et la voir
remporter une troisième coupe de la
france
écoutez c'est un déchirement pour moi de
vous annoncer que le 33e tabac de
l'histoire de l'émission et
je ne m'en vante pas seulement je te
passe et c'est pas de ma faute et c'est
un travail collectif mais exactement
merci à vous merci vous voulez voir ce
travail collectif
regardez tout temps baba mariages pour
une lune de miel qui aiment le miel ici
à part isabelle dans ses oreilles
faut-il retirer le césar de roman
polanski il ya une polémique il ya
surtout une pétition qui est en train de
grandir bondir grossir grossir grossir
on dirait castaldi avant comme j'aime
arrêtez les césar les gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent tu m'aimes tu as un petit peu
d'alcool à 90 n'ont rien d'acquis était
pas on aura jean michel cohen dans un
instant quand vous n'avez pourtant vous
serez médecins m'ont repéré ou indirecte
[Musique]
et toujours plus mon cadeau de mariage
ah oui ouais et alors et le salaire que
vous avez tous les jours c'est pas un
cadeau c'est un salaire c'est mon
travail
bassil faye est vraiment votre travail
je peux dire c'est dirais que c'est un
cadeau quand elles marchent à 100 même
plutôt unanimes il ya le colonel virilo
ce qui vous attend pour l'opération
kaboul
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup de rencontres insolites
mais elle elle fait que des rencontres
un sonar tgv pour aller à lyon parce que
devait monter sur scène guide michelin
si le guide michou vous fait pas bouger
vous d'accord sinon vous bouger pendant
l'émission là j'avais un petit bonbon
dans la bouche mais glycémie excusez moi
oui à votre eberle a pas mangé depuis 20
minutes
[Rires]
[Musique]
toulouse